man muss immer so sehen leute die hecke
oder poggenburg die reifen der afb wegs
ist die bürgerliche maske runter eine
wichtige funktion
abgesehen davon der hacke ist beurlaubt
lehrer
das heißt wenn der fliegt dann
unterrichtet er wieder draußen steht vor
bernd oelkers alter schule in bad sooden
allendorf in hessen
china hat man sich da schon auf das
schlimmste eingestellt
natürlich an die war die schule ist
vorbereitet die lehrer haben das gebäude
komplex havariert
sie müssen bedenken der hecke ist
beamter auf lebenszeit
wenn man ihn einmal an der backe hat sie
nie wieder los vor stehe aber könnte man
nämlich wenig los auf irgendeine stelle
am arsch der welt versetzen
ich bitte sie das hier ist das
grenzgebiet zwischen thüringen und
hessen
die haben die meisten leute direkte
vorfahren mit vier beinen
ich mache das hier auf der welt der
haupteingang geschichte und sport hat
heute ihr früher unterrichtet ja nicht
immer ganz einfach war bei deiner
rechten gesinnung ich nein
versuchen sie mal völker beispiel wenn
ich nur ein voll gegen darf sie meinen
man sollte den mann er nicht wieder auf
kinder loslassen ein wie verrückt oder
lieber bundeskanzler werden
ja selbst wenn wir dann drei wochen
später wieder in polen einmarschieren
spaß ergreift sie erfolgreich werden
kannst du nicht kaputtmachen gucken wie
man was der hecke gepostet klima bildung
bei facebook hatte behauptet die
thüringische regierung wurde geld für
klassenfahrten kürzen weil sie alle vier
analsex workshops ausgibt was ist das
geld für diese fragen wurden uhr gekürt
weil viele schulen ihr budget dafür
nicht abgerufen haben wenn alles aber so
klingt geiler verbaute linke aus deiner
nachbarschaft wollen deine kinder
verschwunden
was könnte man denn machen um merkels
rückkehr ins lärm noch zu verhindern
ich möchte nicht viel leider allerdings
hatte jetzt die schulleitung mit ganz
tolle idee wie finde wenn der wären
wirklich zurückkommt dann muss er einen
ganz neuen fachbereich leiten den sie
nur für ihn gegründet haben den nennt
sich islamische religionslehrer
kombiniert mit homosexueller transgender
forschung ja
das ist ein neuer kollege also sein
neuer kollege er freut sich schon total
auf die zusammenarbeit und ich werde das
mit bestimmt für beide eine sehr
intensive erfahrung das wollen wir doch
schwer hoffen viele auf
[Applaus]